dormez la france mise sur le niger comme
le principal point d'appui de cette ré
articulations mais aussi sur le tchad
bonjour mamadou djite et bayer vous êtes
à n'djamena le tchad va donc jouer un
rôle clé et s'inquiètent sur place
bonjour julien alors
france et interpelle dit inquiète dans
une certaine mesure lorsqu'on sait que
1400 soldats canadiens sont sur le
terrain les opérations la décision de la
france de six années de se retirer
impacte fortement les forces tchadiennes
présent au mali et qui travaille
conjointement avec les forces de la
mission barkan dont le quartier général
se trouve n'djamena les offices
italienne contacté par nos soins les
reconnaissent et déplore cette perte
énorme pour en terme de logistique de
renseignement militaire et un appui
aérien il se pose bien évidemment à
plusieurs questions pour rappel les
sauver sadien sont au mali dans le cadre
de la mission onusienne détenus du sénat
pour la stèle de son du mali la question
de leur retrait n'est pas à l'ordre du
jour car seules les nations unies
peuvent décider de leur sort une
question pourtant
en tout cas la question de leur
prolongation va être posée en juin d'un
jouet reprochait et aussi selon nos
informations il ya un renfort de 1000
soldats tchadiens qui se prépare à
déployer ce qu'on appelle en renfort
forces stationnées
pour finir il vous souviendra que le
ministère malien des affaires étrangères
et de la coopération avait annoncé en
décembre dernier son accord pour le
déploiement des mille soldats canadiens
supplémentaires pour renforcer le
contingent qui est déjà sur ps qui est
dans le nord du mali nos sources au sein
de l'armée avance que ça c'était en
prévision de ce départ pré-annoncé et
pour finir ce qui est d'autant plus que
le jazz est là des contingents le plus
touché en termes de perte en vie humaine
donc là le départ des armées françaises
c'est sûr que ça va aller vite et ça va
exposer le sol indien c'est ce qui
ressort de là des gens qu'on a
interrogés notamment les officiels comme
la population merci pour ces éléments
mamadou djite éveillé depuis une djamena